democrats are supposed to be the party
of personal choice that favors greater
personal freedom in social and personal
affairs and at least on these issues
that isn't the case hi I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer friesen TV and we're here
with reason foundations pulling director
Emily Ekins Emily thanks for sitting
down with us thanks for having me you're
here to talk about the latest poll
results from December and one of the big
issues that you ask people about was
minimum wage so can you talk about some
of your findings you said they were
pretty surprising yes well at first we
asked the same question that all the
other polls are asking and find the same
result that nearly three-fourths of
Americans favor raising the minimum wage
to ten dollars and ten cents an hour
what we did that's different than the
other polls it was we followed it up
with a follow-up question asking people
if they would favor or oppose raising
the minimum wage if it were to cause
some employers to lay off employees or
hire fewer workers in that situation
support flips and a majority oppose
raising the minimum wage if it were
associated with costs and so ultimately
that's the question at hand will raising
the minimum wage actually cost us
something or is it a benefits only
proposition I think the debate we should
be having is about what the minute what
minimum wage jobs are supposed to be so
we asked Americans what they thought and
nearly two-thirds of Americans view
minimum wage jobs as stepping stone jobs
for low-skilled workers to gain new
skills they're not supposed to be
long-term they're not supposed to be
able to support a family only about a
quarter of Americans view minimum wage
jobs as those that should support a
family that should be long-term jobs you
go into asking about specific consumer
products and whether the government
should be involved in regulations like
the DNA testing kit 23andme 3d printed
guns electronic cigarettes were there
any patterns or trends that you notice
we found that overwhelmingly majorities
of Americans believe that these types of
products should be allowed so genetic
testing kits that tell people about
their DNA a majority think those should
be allowed not banned a majority think
that people should be allowed to smoke
e-cigarettes play violent video games
play online poker and nearly
three-fourths of Americans think people
should be allowed
to eat trans fats if they want to and
drink caffeinated energy drinks and
these are all consumer goods or
activities that the government is trying
to regulate alternatively a majority of
americans think that 3d printed guns
should be illegal so for these issues in
particular did you see any trends and
Republicans versus Democrats and
nannying behavior so we compared
responses to these questions between
Democrats and Republicans and on these
questions that we asked about Democrats
were actually statistically more likely
to favor government prohibiting
behaviors and Republicans now
alternatively if we had asked other
types of questions like about
pornography about drug use Republicans
would have been more likely to support
government intervention but the reason
this is meaningful is that Democrats are
supposed to be the party of personal
choice that favors greater personal
freedom in social and personal affairs
and at least on these issues that isn't
the case there's a lot on criminal
justice in the poll can you talk about
what Americans thought about mandatory
minimums or anything else particularly
relevant yes the truth is most Americans
don't really know much about mandatory
minimums many of them probably don't
even know what they are but when we
asked people about that nearly
three-fourths of Americans favor
eliminating mandatory minimum prison
sentences for nonviolent offenders and
instead they would prefer that judges be
able to make sentencing decisions on a
case-by-case basis what about with
broader local law enforcement powers
militarization of police we asked people
about that a majority oppose local
police departments using drones and
armored vehicles they just don't think
it's necessary to protect the public
only about thirty seven percent believe
it's necessary to protect the public
interest great well Emily thanks again
for sharing that with us thanks for
having me for the full poll results go
to reason.com forward slash pull prison
TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
you